I'll answer for you way more opportunity
for all of you everybody keeps thinking
oh I missed it I missed YouTube I missed
my moment I wanted to be the expert on
butterflies this person just popped off
on Tick Tock or shorts I can't do it
everyone keeps saying they missed it
expectations for the Creator economy is
huge huge opportunities everyday people
building profiles of content are taking
money away from the biggest brands in
the world who are going to spend it with
you versus running a television
commercial the opportunity is enormous
not everyone's going to make a million
dollars a year but for every person
watching this you have the ability to
start building a side career side
opportunity making 10 or 15K a year
talking about the St Louis Cardinals
talking about fashion take advantage of
the way the world actually runs now the
opportunities are enormous you should
start making videos about things you
want to talk about not what you think is
going to get views and likes on the
platform don't dance if you don't know
how to dance talk about [ __ ] you know